the show is so good and it is so
wonderful to see all the just really
positive fun stuff that's happening for
the kardashians right now
this makes me so happy she's never had a
reaction like that for me and it's
happened like a few times
courtney i i gotta i gotta catch up with
you a little bit yes you did a practice
run on the wedding congratulations thank
you
so when is the real wedding and what
will that look like because we're really
seeing your love story with your soul
mate on the new show you are um we don't
know yet we're just you know living our
best lives and
yeah
big small
wedding we don't know we don't know okay
we don't know well there's a lot going
on with you we will also see this
beautiful fertility journey travis and i
want to have a baby
put the sample in this cup
we'll take our mics off you know get the
audio what has it been like to be on the
path to baby with travis um i think it's
been
i mean it's a beautiful thing that we'd
love to have happen um but
you know the journey is a bit hard for
any women who have been on it and
emotional
yeah
uh you are all the support system and we
see that so much with the new show life
without cameras was a big change for us
i think it's time to see a whole new
side of the family how much do you all
love seeing courtney this happy oh we
all love it this is her time to shine
baby
[Music]
you